so let's look at some example adapts so
i already mentioned the first step the
first example i want to give you is a
game and in fact there are many games i
kind of encourage you to look at uh the
site called dap review that looks at all
sorts of apps that have been posted out
there all sorts of games and various
prediction markets and business logics
that have been posted but this game is
kind of incredible in that first of all
it's an extremely well designed game
very very clever but to me it's more
than a game to me it's basically a way
to manage crypto assets
it just so happens that the crypto asset
is what's called a kitty yeah so what
happens here is uh you um send ether to
the cryptokitties game and as a result
uh you basically are it's recorded that
you own a particular cat yeah so this is
what these cats look like every cat is
different you own your cat uh and
you remember the cat cat now belongs to
you
and no one can take it away from you
unless they have your secret key
yeah so there's a bit of a description
here about how these kitty works you can
kitties work you can actually breed the
kitty with other kitties then you get
off springs and you can sell the
offsprings to other people so in fact um
when you buy these kitties you can kind
of interact with other players so it's
kind of a fun game to illustrate how
crypto assets operate but again it's an
example of storing an asset on the
blockchain in this case it just happens
to be a digital description of a cat um
but it's there it's yours and no one can
take it away from you and the
interesting thing is um
you know even if the company disappears
even if cryptokitties as a company no
longer exists it doesn't matter the dap
is on the blockchain the dap is going to
continue operating your
kitty belongs to you you can continue
trading it using the blockchain and so
on and so forth yeah so um
this is kind of the beauty of this of
these dapps even though somebody wrote
the code
and they might disappear or lose
interest it doesn't matter the code is
posted on a blockchain and it's gonna
run forever
the other thing to remember which i say
again and again and again the data is
public which means that um in fact third
parties can build on top of the game
and in fact there's a site called uh
kitty battles where i could take the
kitty that i own and i can erase it
against a kitty that you own and see who
wins there's a site called kitty hats
where you can buy hats for your kitty
and those are separate daps yeah so it's
one dap that uses data that belongs to
another app but because the data is
public there's nothing preventing 1dap
for in fact building on the data of
another dap and so you can build these
add-on products that people might want
to buy and store and again once you buy
a hat it's yours forever and no one can
take it away from you
so maybe this looks a little silly to
you but once you play with it um
you will you'll kind of realize you know
there's something different about
playing these games than playing uh like
regular games on uh that are off the
blockchain and just to show you that
this thing is um is real let me mention
that when cryptokitties launched there
was a huge spike in the number of
transactions in the ethereum blockchain
as i said this is implemented as a as a
smart contract as a dap on the ethereum
blockchain you can see here um like uh
in the first couple of days that it
launched there was massive massive uh
invest investment from a lot of people
in buying kitties so it's a game that
people really kind of enjoy working uh
we're playing with and um and owning and
then trading and in fact even when you
look now there's constantly transactions
um happening on the uh on the ethereum
blockchain related to to crypto
exchanges yeah so in fact as i said you
can look at the site's tap review and it
will show you all the transactions that
happen on a daily basis and there are
many transactions on a daily basis
related to cryptokitties quite quite
fascinating
but there are lots of other examples of
dapps that have been equally successful
in fact lots of business logic has been
encoded as dapps um so for example there
are prediction markets uh like if you
want to uh
uh predict have a contract about the
price of bitcoin relative to the price
of ethereum
you can have a contract about that um
and uh you know
basically transact with other people in
that sense so augur is a prediction
markets dap devoted to this uh there are
stable coins implemented as adap um so
for example pegged to the us dollar so
you can look at some of how these stable
coins work
and there are many many of these
business logic applications encoded as
dapps the question you always need to
ask is why do we put why do we need to
put this on the blockchain is the
blockchain the right a mechanism for uh
the dap that i want to build and so the
the uh you know in some cases the answer
is no and in some cases the answer is
yes um in particular if you put
if you do decide to put a dap on the
blockchain you know business logic on
the bot on the blockchain what it means
is that the business logic itself is
enforced by the blockchain protocol so
again the miners are the ones that are
enforcing the business logic so the
rules in the code are followed correctly
and they can never be changed and
moreover
you get transparency so in fact there's
no need to trust third parties everyone
can look on the blockchain and make sure
the rules are followed correctly now i
should caveat this a little bit in that
in fact there is a mechanism by which
you can change the code if you decide
that your old code needs to be updated
in fact there is a way that the owner
can update the code that
implements a particular dapp but all of
that is going to be completely
transparent so it'll show on the
blockchain blockchain that the code was
changed from one version to another
version and both versions are going to
be available for the public to inspect
so everything is transparent everything
is verifiable and the code
has to be run the way it was written
that's basically enforced by the miners
okay so that's kind of the
the interesting aspect of putting
business logic on the blockchain